[Music]
is it wild for you that it's been over
50 years since you released your first
album it is wild i mean i'm so proud to
still be here but compared to people
like tony bennett and nick and keith and
people that i looked up to and i was
always you know 10
20 years younger than them i still feel
like a young pup turn down these voices
inside my head
the fact that i got offered a record
deal when i was 21 and i said okay give
me complete artistic control you can't
tell me anything about what kind of
music to do who to work with what to
dress like i'll work really hard but you
can't tell me anything about how to make
my record and that's exactly why bonnie
is so beloved how do you react when
people refer to you as an icon and a
legend it makes me feel pretty important
and i'm grateful that they feel that way
you know everybody wants to be validated
and looked up to and that makes me feel
wonderful so i'm really glad to be at
the point in my career where i mean
something are there any artists or bands
out right now that you are loving that
you're drawing inspiration from well i'm
pretty impressed with adele and billy
eilish love their music i'm always
amazed at the poise and the
togetherness that people like
together meaning they have it together
for such a young age taylor swift the
way she's been handling her career the
art is her on her instruments she's just
incredible so an amazing
amazing inspiration to a new generation
of young women and bonnie will certainly
continue to inspire with her new music
the singer songwriter and activist 21st
studio album just like that was shaped
by current events
[Music]
just wasted time
there's been a lot going on and i just
thought just like that your life can
change would be a good title